where the pacers of the quarters 17 to 7
and they were up 13 at the house there
comes Butler Warren spinning it around
and Butler not happy with that had to be
restrained by Leroy Richardson Jimmy do
not take yourself out of that New York
weekend
oh don't don't read lips heat nation do
not read lips
Butler get really agitated by that
spinner and foul from TJ Warren and the
officials will take a look
Butler is still very upset
[Applause]
need Jimmy to come down here he's just
too important to the team to get tossed
right now they need him in this game
he's got to calm down
got fired up cuz he really beat and hat
warned totally beat warned grabbed him
to spin them around we're gonna take
several looks at this here watch
Lauren's hands grabbed him by the left
arm and spun him around held him Leroy
Richardson who is it as 25th season as
an official did a good job of diffusing
what could have been an explosive
situation
Leroy Richardson 12 years in the United
States Navy an underwater sea
surveillance specialists that time on
dry land did a very good job of
diffusing what could have been a huge
problem for both Butler and TJ warning
well said partner well said
look at me Roy look how quick he was in
there that's terrific officiant it is
get ahead of it for four things back
we're reviewing this right now trying to
figure out what what they're gonna do
but you know it's quick it's clearly
gonna be a foul initially unworn and
then from there we'll see what the call
is both guys going chest to chest we've
really probably asking the folks in
Secaucus how good did I look breaking
that up
I would think that you know typically
what they'll try to do is even it out
from a technical standpoint you know
really to diffuse guys from having the
next one if they don't see these guys up
it could become a problem where it boils
into a potential fight if they give them
double texts than they're worried about
picking up the next T and being thrown
out of the game John you're next Jeff
could be working for the league that's
exactly what it is double technical
folks 140 JT warm the other for Jimmy
Butler and out of that scrum give John
karate and Leroy Richardson a plus Thank
You Barney but look I enjoy hanging here
with you too much Johnny we talk a lot
about teams making the three Miami can
certainly do that 11 of 23
how about defending the three the Pacers
have hit just for their 16 triples
mending them under with the rest of
Miami's defense and that Jimmy Butler
calm down just had a pleasant exchange
with Pacers head coach Nate McMillan
well not a shooting foul was the third
team foul on Indiana in the quarter
komm prevents the heat go back to work
ahead by 23 and warm right back on
butler auxilary put a shoulder into the
chest of Lauren and then Lauren just got
himself tossed out of the game for
Taunton now neither player showing much
of the way of poise right there oh my
what's gonna happen I don't know if you
saw that on TV or not but TJ Warren that
is a no no my friend
that's why Warren's gonna be tossed
right now this is his second technical
foul this is why it's so important if
they call those first technical fouls
they have no toleration at all
TJ Warren who's the leading scorer for
the Indiana